we are right here on the rich eisen show
back here
in our los angeles studio our buddy from
good morning football and ten
questions with kyle brandt fantastic
podcast on the ringer in spotify back
here on the show how are you kyle
rich i'm ready for the game day tweet
from rich eisen the it's
championship sunday people it gets me
fired up
i love it each and every week you keep
that in your in your draft folder
you just just you know i do it i do it
when i wake up there's two reasons why i
do that kyle
yeah one is um it's just a fun way to
start the day
uh on football and two it's my way of
letting the producers know i did
uh i didn't sleep through my alarm
i'm serious sign of life it's just
holding up today's newspapers say that
you're still alive
it's pilot start your engines
into it i always look forward to it each
and every week but this is the best one
of the year
i'm usually sending it at like four in
the morning and i just wanna it's it's a
way to let the producers know don't
worry i'm awake
it really is it's i like it you know
it's like it's multiple purpose
um i can't you know i can't wait for it
because and i've talked about it with
wilbon
uh and uh earlier on the show and i want
to hit it with you here
that this is uh for either victor
in the nfc championship game a capstone
it's a capstone i know that there's
another game to come but just to make it
to the super bowl rogers who
you were one of the first to interview
after jordan love got drafted yeah
i believe he was uh you're was he your
inaugural guest on your podcast
okay episode one he's sitting there with
his help comet
background and you know sipping on a
drink like he was probably on draft
night when jordan love got drafted
that his response to all this is all
good
ari lax i take my own advice uh i made
the uh i made the super bowl um
and i'm the mvp of the the league i win
this you know i'm gonna play in the
super bowl and the night before i'm
gonna win the mvp
and then there's brady saying okay well
how am i going to
how am i going to do in a new spot
without bill and the patriots i'm making
the super bowl
in in my own building first quarterback
to ever do that i mean
the stakes for this game uh are huge
tremendous i can't wait it's incredible
yeah and
the fact that tom brady is one game away
from saying for the rest of his life
hi uh my name is tom brady i've been to
ten super bowls
ten the next closest quarterback was
john elway with five
and i'm now doubling up john away a
living legend because i've been to
ten of them and make no mistake the
tenth one
was real real sweet because it is a solo
project from which i broke away from the
empire that i did the first nine
and they got another one it's it's a
crazy crazy
i mean i know the guy has a lot of
things to brag about and be happy about
ten super bowls is a joke
whether he wins or not you know
sometimes rich it's
it's not even just about how many you
win of course but history will that will
be that what
is said about brady it's like you know
coach k i think he's got somewhere
you know the twelve final fours or
something else how many championship
final fours meryl streep has 19 oscar
nominations shouldn't win them all
doesn't win most of them she got 19
nominations tom brady will go to 10
super bowls
and with me you know the exhibit a for
how hard it is to get to the super bowl
even to
is that rogers hasn't been the two
rogers is one of many super bowls
brad johnson he's been to as many as as
rex grossman and he's the best guy to
ever throw a pass in history i think
it is wild to think that that he can't
get the two and brady's about to get to
10
and to bring it full circle what you
mention this is the season that aaron
rodgers started and
i did sit down and talk to me sat down
with what appeared to be a bucket of
scotch
on a saturday night and straight up said
yeah i don't i don't think i'm finishing
my career with the packers i i'll move
on
they'd made their bed they're going to
move on to this kid at one point and i'm
going to be gone
i don't even know if that's true anymore
how could you win mvp and get to the
super bowl and then get rid of the guy
he might have changed the whole world
it's crazy it is
and uh brady even if he doesn't win this
um
last week against brees was his 32nd
career playoff win
we want to talk about doubling people up
uh that's double
the number two uh on that list and
that's his childhood hero john montana
he's doubled up joe montana
and career postseason victories 32 he's
32 for 43
in the playoffs he's he's he's hitting
he's hit that's his average
32 for 43 in terms of winning in the
playoffs against the best teams in the
league and the best defenses
um we could go back and forth rich i i
know you're a tennis man i'll go right
to the net right back at you with
another breaking nugget that i found
okay tom brady if you remember week one
his debut the buccaneers was at the
superdome and they played against the
saints
it did not go well he threw a pick six
in that game to janoris jenkins
that interception is the last one he has
thrown
on the road this season currently tom
brady
is riding the longest streak in nfl
history
without a road interception that many
past attempts without an interception on
the road it's it's a crazy streak no
one's ever done it and no one
so all this attention rogers is playing
incredible rogers never played but it's
all true
brady is playing phenomenal as well
it's i didn't i wasn't aware of that no
one in history since i think it's since
1948 since they were tracking it
has gone longer on the road without
throwing interception than tom brady
current to date
so what do you think all said and done
which 12 makes it
kyle it's tough to pick against the one
in green
you know we were talking about the the
typical you know the cold and the
weather and lambo and
i said on the air i said you know we
rogers has played in it for years but if
i'm brady i'm borrowing the the phrase
you know from
from bain in the dark knight rises where
if i'm brady i'm saying you know
you merely adopted the cold i was born
in it
and tom brady was winning championship
games in the cold when aaron rodgers was
a butte community
college and he's been doing it a long
time i said this on the air
later that day i got a text from a
member of the green bay packers
on the defensive side who chose to
remain anonymous
who said you got that wrong it's totally
different i don't care if brady was
there for years
living in these conditions is different
from that moment when you get off the
plane and hit the tarmac and say holy
crap it's freezing how we're gonna win
this game
the weather will be a factor and the
packers will be dealing with the better
i really think that and i'm not picking
against
against the 12 in green i'm going to go
with the packers i think the packers are
going to be in the super bowl
okay so kyle brandt here on the rich
eisen show let's flip the script here
um you know you know the our our
mandalorian quarterback
and josh allen with his baby yoda's
bringing uh
uh uh uh beasley and he's bringing digs
with him and he's uh he's going to
kansas city where
i'm i'm going to have to assume it'll be
mahomes
so let's just say it's mahomes but
coming off of the week and the injuries
and the
concussion and also the the tight games
that they've been playing how do you
suss the afc
um championship game here it's wild to
me that the bills could be in the super
bowl again oh yeah and it's there's a
funny hypothetical rich
or a quandary rather i have a bills uh
friend who
i hang out with sometimes and i pose
this question to him
i said as a bills fan who's been through
it all since you know the eighties
would you rather lose this title game
play real tough
you lose on a field goal to the chiefs
and homes okay the tough great season
or you get to the super bowl
and you lose again you've lost five
straight super bowls and
you lose to your nemesis of the last two
decades tom brady
which and his brain was in a pretzel and
he said i can't get the super news again
to brady maybe it's better to lose the
title game
and i said the hell with that take the
shot throw the punch
get to the super bowl win the game and i
have to tell you rich
i feel a certain kind of way about the
bills i really do is that because hold
on
hold on is that or not is that the
reason that bill's going to win the game
are you is that because is that because
is that because they asked you to do the
hype tape for them last week and you did
and it worked and all that i mean is
are you are you are you are you drinking
the uh the bills juice is that what
basically i'm saying
uh by choice not because i have to am
under no obligations pick the bills
not at all i it has nothing to do with
the hype speech it has everything to do
with
they've lost threes three games all
season two
when the game was moved and adjusted
wildly because of covet and one
hail mary one of those was to the chiefs
and there was a slew of guys on the
bills were not out there that day i
think it's a different team
i just i'm riding them i think they're
great and i think that they win
almost every game by double digits
including against the ravens so they
held the three points
i think it's buffalo buffalo versus
green bay
my nine-year-old cooper is the one who
told me that in my office two weeks ago
when i said
coop they're giving me one more mulligan
right here to to
uh to predict the super bowl what do you
think and he goes packers over bill's
dad and i'm like okay i'm going on the
air and saying it
awesome i like it i'm with you guys kyle
i feel you you do huh you do
i feel a bill's moneyline packer
i mean the chiefs don't they really
don't ever lose mahomes almost never
loses at all like
why why do you feel so good now but
parlay's aside i i feel when i watch
them play they just
don't look right they don't look like
the juggernaut we've been used to seeing
in the last couple of years
i think the toe is worse than maybe
mahomes and the chiefs are letting on
you could kind of see it
before he got knocked out on sunday i
just don't feel it this year and i feel
like buffalo
it's their time it's like it's kind of
like what you did with the browns uh
her brook speech it's the bill's time
right now and i just kind of feel it you
can feel it watching the games
uh josh allen is just playing on another
level but but also this like
last year and i this is something
because kelsey's going to be on game day
morning on sunday i interviewed him
right from this desk
uh on tuesday and i this is what i said
to him again i don't know what's going
to make the piece or not
but here's the thing last year the
chiefs were like i don't know because
they got to come from behind every game
now they're not winning by enough and
we're still wondering
and they won the championship and
mahomes is mahomes and kelsey's even
better
and tyree kills even better and you know
and then le'veon bell's they're running
back it's not it's not the williams kids
you know i mean like
they're actually a better team when you
look at it this year
um and and their coaching staff was
hardly poached for defending super bowl
champ
either now they're just we're wondering
where are the blowouts
as opposed to well now you got to keep
coming back and that's
my you know will we ever be happy with
the way the chiefs win i i don't know
that's my two cents on that i think it's
a good two cents
i uh rich i have to i have to pick your
brain for something you mentioned game
day morning yes sir um
there's there's chatter right now that
uh i'm gonna be
thrilled to be joining you okay this
weekend all right and from what i
hear yes there may be a sort of
uh hype man competition between
myself and the play maker as we go ahead
and i just wonder if you have any
insight on that or even advice i
wouldn't ask you to betray michael irvin
but i'm trying to gear up myself
well i think the only way you can take
out michael
irvin in terms of a hype man because
long before the bills asked you to hype
up the uh the uh
the crowd or the fans or the team
michael's been doing that
literally for maybe every single year
you've been on the earth
um so my only suggestion for you
kyle would take a page from dan
campbell's playbook and bite his kneecap
off
and see if he gets up you know just go
all right just go all dan campbell on
him that was some press conference
i'm watching this thing unfold like you
are and he's chewing ankles and eating
eating
femurs and like it reminded me of the
the alleged
oh my god you're an army hammer i i'm
like he's hannibal lecter
i mean like the detroit lions fava beans
and a nice chianti i don't know why
everybody's calling him the dude
because he's rocked up the dude was
drinking white russians and
smoking pot and dreaming of bowling
balls and and stuff like that i mean
he's not that dude
and he looks like jack morris and he
talks like hannibal lecter and he's
coming at you for the detroit alliance
all right we got that and then meanwhile
salah
just holding court and he says get used
to the phrase
all gasps breaks which sounds great but
also rich like that
that literally translates into a car
accident so i don't know
oh my god and the jets used to be owned
by a gas magnet and leon hess and how'd
that work out
oh man what a day what a day i mean
were you were you watching that live
were you on good morning football live
when he was
when dan campbell spoke or that was uh
you know i wish i would have ran to my
tv if i could have i started seeing it
on twitter and i'm saying wait does this
really
and then when i saw the dude thing i'm
like that has to be a photoshop right
now it's real
and then i'm seeing him these
transcripts about him you know eating
kneecaps or doing whatever he's doing
and i'm like that's the real thing
i thought somebody re-edited herself no
it's real so it was not i'm reacting to
it now
so here's the thing what if what if you
had you were showing it that is real i
can't believe it it says head coach
slash the dude
on the wall and you know so so what if
you
um again i don't know how your process
goes creatively
with the fantastic good morning football
uh production staff
but what if you had said here's here's
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna fire up the
lions i'm gonna be hannibal lecter and
i'm gonna talk about
biting kneecaps and kicking teeth in
they would have told you
you can't do that you can't go on the
air and say that i mean you can't do
that
that's that's sadistic and it's terrible
and then the coach actually says that
so now i think that's your next year
when you're firing up the lines you know
get uh just leave out multiple migs
that's all i'm telling you just leave
him out yeah
mix takes it to another level
was heard speaking to him late last
night and then yeah it makes a swallow
his own tongue so maybe that's all part
of the plan too it's getting crazy in
detroit
i like it at least it's different i know
it sure is all right kyle so
uh this gives me again my my uh my zoom
to prepare for the six hour game day
morning that starts at 9 a.m eastern on
sunday we're gonna have that on
on saturday i i i good luck man you
versus mike will be fantastic that will
be i'll leave it all on the field i
promise you rich what a great idea
thanks a call kyle you'd be well
of course the one and only kyle bryant
everybody
multiple migs kicked it up another notch
yes he did
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here